I don't know James Corden I I've seen
him he seems like a guy who behind
closed doors is a an [ __ ] that's what
he seems like he seems like a guy that
other British people would go like ah
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what I mean
like they just I I guarantee no British
looks like him oh that stuffed [ __ ]
he stopped you know what I mean oh I I
you know it's like I couldn't look it
got Pagan okay he had one show in
Britain like this and it was great and a
[ __ ] and the second and it's like is
he fat or not it's like make up your
mind it's mental so like it's like so uh
so he's he look at this they but okay so
I looked into this because I talked
about it on congratulations in my
podcast I I this is the kind of thing
though that it's dude he was a dick kind
of to a waiter and now it's all over TMZ
and [ __ ] well but why would you he was
rough and then he goes if you don't give
uh me and my wife free drinks and all
the other drinks around the house I'd
hate to leave a Yelp review for you of
course dick dick and so that guy was
like well before you do it I'm gonna go
out and before you get me and ruin my
business right but my whole point is
this social media [ __ ] [ __ ] just handle
it with each other dude this whole up
because now this guy Keith McNally or
whatever [ __ ] knows if he goes on
it's gonna make headlines it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] walk up to be like yo
[ __ ] leave it leave a yep that's
a dick move you know if you do that I'm
gonna bam yeah yeah or you can be cool
Devil's Advocate over here please thank
you
um what recourse does regular people
have of somebody that they perceive as
with this sort of influence and you know
a Yelp review from him is gonna go viral
and [ __ ] the guy's business so like they
said okay here's how we're gonna combat
this we're gonna combat this like repo
now like hey be nice to people because
it's Gonna Get out no no I I it's kind
of like but by the way I'm with you on
like let's say when people don't tip and
then and then they're like they're
they're they're posting that on the
internet right crystalia doesn't tip
right look at this receipt right okay I
don't like that but at the same time hey
Tiff no I understand that but like it's
the only recourse they have I get it but
like these are these two instances if
you you read these two instances one of
them is like all right you [ __ ] up the
order yeah he could have been nice the
other one what if he had a dude what if
I mean you don't know what the [ __ ]
person's going through but twice though
Chris once I forgive twice all right I
do understand but the other one isn't as
bad if you don't have the first one but
you do have the first one and that's
what the guy's going off of yeah I
understand but but my point is
one of them to me he was a big dick the
other one he wasn't he was like kind of
like at the same place yes yeah
which action came first the smaller one
and then the big one like he was like
giving the guy a chance big one then
smaller one he was a dick really nice
moment this guy calls the dude out for
being a dick this whole people saying
[ __ ] James Corden yes that's that's not
like that that's you're like the mob in
town yeah it's like they got to deal
with it yeah that's what I'm trying but
the thing the two-man is uh this is uh
do you know who I am situation yeah
right like do you know who I am I should
be treated extra special no that's what
that is James cord is mean to her then
I'm pissed I know these mean to her it's
it's the good and bad of social media
it's like a double-edged sword and it
sucks